when you audition for Curb Your
Enthusiasm I remember this story that
you were watching Curb Your Enthusiasm
had already been on for a couple of
seasons you turn to your wife and you
said hey I should be on this show this
is good she even said she agreed right
you go in for an audition you knew Larry
from your days riding in Saturday Night
Live you walk in and you see Larry
standing there for the audition and you
walk over and smack them in the face
no I see I do this thing I tell you know
I even get this advice to other actors I
always make it a point to what I'm going
for a role it's what the [ __ ] I do yeah
I walk into the room as the character I
don't [ __ ] walk in the room as JB and
say I'm JB Smoove I'm about to play the
role of Leon and they've turned [ __ ]
Leon on that's [ __ ] see that means
you got to change gears now you got to
get into your [ __ ] zone why not get
into the zone in the [ __ ] waiting
room right already started doing with
the I started doing mannerisms I said I
know who the [ __ ] this dude is right so
I read the sides I said I know what the
[ __ ] Leon is I don't know a few Leon's
hell I feel so lean on that
[ __ ] house who is Leon who is
he really when you when you sat there
before you went into the audition you
had read the script or a loose kind of
idea of what this guy is who was Leon
this character that you were about to
portray Leon was a guy I felt like a guy
who lived day to day he's a somewhat of
an opportunist but he's a guy that got
your back this hard to it he's a guy
he's got the condom in your wallet he's
the dude who you would go and take with
you to fight a ticket he's a guy you
would go to court with you know he's a
guy he's a good guy he would take this
do to help you break up with a girl he's
that dude he's I do not you I don't take
JB smooth to fight a ticket but I would
take Leon do it ask me I will say
[ __ ] no
wouldn't have anything to do with you
well that's a back when you walked into
Larry David you knew who Leon was and
you came in and you proved that Wyatt
why did you smack him but did smack
laughs no no I never smacked anybody oh
but here's what I wanted to relate to
the cat as the character I said here's
exactly what the [ __ ] I said right cuz I
don't believe in violence and [ __ ] so
what I did was this I like to walk in
the room as the character so that way
you see how I walk in the room you see
my mannerisms immediately
now when I walked into the room as Leon
these [ __ ] you should have seen
her face on these [ __ ]
everybody looked confused like what the
[ __ ] just happened what a [ __ ] is this
dude right and why is he coming in like
this
you don't mean yeah I can see it in
their faces they were like they looked
at each other like what the [ __ ] is
going on here I came in here like this
mm-hmm they told me I said okay okay JB
you're gonna improv Larry directly so I
walk them to Larry this is the [ __ ] I
said as character that's okay Larry
let's do this [ __ ] good improv right
okay let's make it happen I don't know
this is [ __ ] improv
I might [ __ ] around a slap in the face I
don't know anything could happen right
now his face was like [ __ ] but I wanted
that I want it back
see what that does is this allows those
producers those directors to see the
character immediately today understand
what you were doing they caught on
because once I sat down and I did my
little Leon head tilt yeah and I just
was [ __ ] like this they got it they
[ __ ] started laughing their asses off
did they offer you the part right then
and there or [ __ ] no no they made you a
nun of course they made me wait but
here's the thing that does they told me
after the fact that they didn't know who
Leon was until I walked in the room
you had your take on it and which is
great because what that was is that you
didn't open a told me that you didn't
open your mouth yet right [ __ ] guy
but that's the power of mannerisms
that's the power of improv that's the
power I'm not going on that [ __ ]
with a goddamn plan because you stuck to
that goddamn plan and a plan only works
one [ __ ] time
bathroom and I sit down on a toilet my
Johnson hangs in the water that's just
such nonsense what are you saying that
for it's a little [ __ ] toilet my [ __ ]
goes under the water like I like this
it's almost like a grabs is [ __ ] head
just like you love being on you can't
repeat a goddamn plan you got one chance
to do that [ __ ] plan you love [ __ ]
up you love being on curb right Curb
Your Enthusiasm love it